did Donald Trump have a deeply thought
out strategy when he gave the go-ahead
to the assassination of quasi masala
mani or was it just on a whim the answer
is probably the latter but we don't know
what we do know was that both presidents
George W Bush and Barack Obama were
given the opportunity to be rid of
soleimani
when they were in office and both
decided against it well we also know for
sure is that the world is a more
dangerous place today thanks to trump
having promised the revenge for solomon
is death the iranians had little option
but to react
hence the bombing of these two US bases
in Iraq on Tuesday night but if that's
the end of their response will trump be
seem to have won and if they do react
again Trump will have a little option
but to hit back even harder it is scary
stuff and the danger is that we end up
with another Middle East war the very
thing that Trump promised he wouldn't
get involved in when he stood in 2016
but then maybe that's what happens when
you elect an unpredictable megalomaniac
as president of the United States break
one word answer did you agree with the
killing of Osama bin Laden I can
understand why they did isn't the answer
do you understand well the answer is
could they have taken him and tried him
I think I would have been very difficult
so I theory with that right so why
wasn't that an assassination it wasn't
such nation of Osama bin Laden yes it
wasn't an assassination he was
assassinated you want general Soleimani
was still alive well what's interesting
is the people who over the years could
have had the opportunity to get locate
which were the Americans but also the
Israelis right up to now they've chosen
not to would you want him still alive
I don't mind if either way you don't
mind have you so long it's a judgment
call as well this is a man who in the
eyes of the British prime minister has
the blood of British troops on his hands
there may well be people watching this
who've lost limbs as a result of the
activities that this man supported hold
on also in the eyes of the United States
also in the eyes of the United Nations
who put a travel
on him and frozen his assets overseas
because they see him as part of a
terrorist organization so it's okay for
the UK it's okay for the u.s. it's okay
for the United Nations it was okay from
your beloved Barack Obama to sanction a
killing but it's not okay I'll explain
so I don't think would've been okay for
anyone to sanction the killing but but
they clearly took a decision not to
sanction his kidding in these Raley's in
particular took a decision when they
could have killed him not to kill him
because they thought the impact than the
effect of it will be too great and that
actually it could lead to war and that's
that's the judgment call you'll make it
I'm not necessarily saying that Trump
was wrong we'll only know what we will
only know this well I think troublesome
they're such a suspicious human being
that you saying was he such strategy or
was it just a whim and what worries me
is it might have been just a whim in
which case I fear for what happens next
yeah so I get the point you're making
Silla money was it was a bad guy he was
responsible for American deaths he was a
very vengeful in 20 figure when Iran's
been hijacking our oil tankers etc but
there's a slight difference when I sama
bin Laden was killed it didn't result in
thousands taken to the streets screaming
death to America everyone there was a
very large consensus they'll say tell
America for any reason you like I
thought if they canceled the Simpsons
they probably say that get it off me I
would also save this in 2011 but Donald
Trump he said that Barack Obama said our
president will attack Iran as the only
way of getting reelected because he has
no strategy
he is pathetic he predicted that in 2011
about Barack Obama and he now he's done
exactly that in an election year to
suggest that this was purely about
protecting national security in America
doesn't look likely would you saw one of
the lordís blows no probably not yeah
this guy's an absolute cancer and I
think he's got no business being around
to inflict more and more misery more
attacks and more pain when you your key
question is did Donald Trump have a
strategy the answer most people would
probably agree is probably not but even
if he did have
strategy and he came and sat and did a
one-to-one PowerPoint presentation with
you Gregg about what that strategy was I
still don't think you'd be happy with it
and the situation is many people are
just jumping on Donald Trump he cannot
do right for doing wrong and when you
look at his support base 84% of his
support base of Republican voters
actually agree with this strike which is
like thank you why did you of course
Pietschmann do worry about all of this
and I agree with you in the sense of I
don't think it was thought through it's
all well and good cutting out that the
head of this cancer in these regions but
what happens and we see it time and time
again you take this head off and then
what's left what bubbles beneath is
you've got all of these different
factions that are absolute poison but
now who's gonna control them who's gonna
contain them and what's gonna happen
next and that is my worry and as we all
hope I really hope that this doesn't
lead to escalation but I also think we
have to be realistic cuz you just said
the world today is undoubtedly a more
scary or dangerous place because of this
action and I'm not sure I necessarily
agree with that I think it it's still
debated whether it was illegal you know
whether drone strike a foreign leader on
foreign soil is is illegal or legal that
is being debated the UN has said already
that this drone strike was probably an
illegal assassination clearly same
sulemani was not one of the good guys
it's good you know he caused untold
damage in Syria as well because he
marshaled all the Shiite of you know
offenses and having said that you know
we're all sitting here being armchair
generals deciding whether a good thing
or a bad thing I think Greg is right I
mean this hasn't made the world a safer
place look at what happened in the
Middle East those tens of thousands of
people chanting death to America you
know America is now safe in Iraq no Iran
but let's hear from an actual general
rather than us I hope that this is a
tactical incident and not a strategic
one but my bones tell me this could very
well be strategic that indeed the next
escalation could be such that the United
States has no choice but to respond with
more force that's a slippery slope to
war and that's what I'm worried about
this president is killing other
recognized representatives of state
governments that's not a good precedent
to have set well I think we won't know
for weeks months years whether Donald
Trump acted to stop or start a war we
know what Trump says but I'm afraid I
think I'm with the myth general
Wilkinson that and let's look at the
reaction from for example Hezbollah
Alaska Alamelu Kia the response to the
blood of Qasem Soleimani and Abu Maddy
will be to oust the American troops from
our entire region the American military
bases the American military ships every
American officer or soldier in our
countries and our territories the
American army killed those and it will
pay the price
the thing is Trump don't do some because
we won't offend Hezbollah I'm not making
that point the general reaction
including Hezbollah oh my god without
sense belong to some to someone like
Mike Trump is that this we haven't a
crazy American American leader who's
willing to John this guy was one of the
Teresa was he know let's have a bit of
perspective here what did what did
Donald Trump say on Twitter he said he
would be willing to disproportionately
react ie
go beyond what would be reasonable in
terms of his reaction to Iran he said to
be willing to bump culturally which is
so absurd I mean let's let's just for a
second turn the tables around turn every
single factor around and pretend like
Trump someone like Trump was in Iran
only for a second let's say you had
somebody in a Middle Eastern country as
Lee delivered Elise in country who
hadn't had nuclear weapons was talking
about hitting America harder and faster
talking about your starting discipline
bombing American cultural sites who most
people even in that country considered
him to be racist against well in that
case white people we would bomb that
country into the dust what songs drunk
is doing right granny had wheel she'd be
a bus what does that it what Donald
Trump is doing right now is showing the
world that he is crazy and that makes
the entire situation a lot
or volatile I was in the States over
Christmas in New Year just talking to
loads of people there is a feeling I got
from now.i disproportionately no
Democrats right there is a feeling that
they think this guy is not Trump but I
want to ask you a question
well you in favor of the Iraq war
initially yes and I was misled and then
I was against it and now right now you
look back and you think that was a
terrible chapter of British and American
the American would have happened without
the blue team yeah it would have may
never happen and and that's the sort of
decision-making I'm talking about that
you don't know whether this decision is
what will what will be the Iranian
reaction over time to this so you never
sends up to a bully why is not much
stood out to him over the last 20 years
you have got to to another matter of
serious global significance